so the purpose of this training is I
just want the fluidity on the one thing
and it seems over the years that people
understand both that you can add the dog
in fluidity of motion when we stick a
knife in there when you take a punch in
there half everything just stops okay so
I also am tempting you with are you over
focusing on the knife and you don't see
the other hand about okay when I want
this energy fluidity I want him to keep
moving that's my goal I don't want to
stop him here are the ways that you can
keep him moving let him move himself do
multiple things right let him move
himself third way second way right is
I'm using that friction so wool friction
third way leverage do you see that this
fourth way of grabbing pulling I vote I
don't want you to count it as a fourth
way okay in this training keep it moving
that's the friction that's not the
leverage do that same thing again to
friction
friction leverage friction
same thing friction leverage friction
and let him go where you going
same technique see that a few right let
him go where he's going over here
leverage friction
Frick same thing even the obvious
ones so I come in here and you're
getting your own neck crank same thing
friction right poom not a neck crank
much okay
[Music]